usa la fórmula de cambio de base para
encontrar el logaritmo en base 5 de 100
y aproximado a la milésima más cercana y
bueno recuerda que yo te decía que
utilizamos bastante la fórmula del
cambio de base porque la mayoría de las
calculadoras no tenemos el logaritmo en
base a 5 de hecho en la mayoría de las
calculadoras solamente tenemos 2
logaritmos el logaritmo en base 10 que
es el log y logaritmo en base en que es
el logaritmo natural por lo tanto la
fórmula del cambio de base me ayuda
bastante para que yo pueda expresar
cualquier logaritmo en base 10 o en base
y en la fórmula de cambio de base que es
lo que me decía que el logaritmo en base
a de b
esto lo podemos ver como el logaritmo en
base x ojo x es una nueva base la base
que tú quieras el logaritmo en base x de
ven ya esto hay que dividirlo entre el
logaritmo en base x entre el logaritmo
con mi nueva base pero tomando en el
logaritmo en base x
y déjenme ponerlo con los mismos colores
para que no te confundas para que todo
quede con mucho sentido bueno esto lo
que me dicen fórmula del cambio de base
que podemos expresar el logaritmo en
cualquier base como una división de
logaritmos en una nueva base en una base
distinta que por cierto en esta ocasión
x puede ser lo es precisamente lo que
queremos drogarme en base 10 el
logaritmo en base y por cierto
seguramente alguna vez has visto el logo
de x pues sólo quiero recordarte que el
log de x es lo mismo que el logaritmo en
base 10 de x cuando alguien pone el log
de x está asumiendo que es lugar y un
base 10 de x y exactamente igual para
lograr y natural si te ponen ln de x
están asumiendo que es el logaritmo en
base de x muy bien pero lo que nos sirve
es el logaritmo en base 10 por lo tanto
podemos escribir aquí un problema el
logaritmo en base 5 de 100 y esto lo
quiero poner usando la fórmula del
cambio de base en un logaritmo con una
nueva base que por cierto vamos a usar
la base 10 entonces esto me va a quedar
como el logaritmo y dejemos ser los
mismos colores logaritmo en base 10 que
es mi nueva base
pero en este caso vale 100 ya esto hay
que dividirlo entre el logaritmo en base
10 que es mi nueva base de 5 es decir el
logaritmo en base 10 de a el logaritmo
en base 10 de 5 y lo bueno es que nos
dejan usar calculadora sin embargo para
la parte de arriba no necesitamos
calculadora el logaritmo envase de 10 de
100 es lo mismo que preguntarnos a qué
potencia tenemos que elevar el 10 para
que nos decían las respuestas 2 entonces
esto se puede simplificar a 2 entre el
lugar y no en base 10 de 5 pero lo que
no sabemos es el logaritmo en base 10 de
5 así que para ello vamos a usar la
calculadora aquí tengo a mi texas 685 y
voy a calcular el logaritmo en base 10
de 5
de hecho mejor vamos a calcular una vez
2 entre el logaritmo en base 10 de 5
pero recuerda que el logaritmo es lo
mismo que logaritmos base de 10 por lo
tanto 2 entre el logaritmo de 5 pues
esto es lo mismo que 2.86 1
2.86 13 pero si lo redondeamos a la
milésima más cercana me va a quedar que
esto es aproximadamente aproximadamente
porque lo estamos redondeando 2.861 y ya
está lo cual tiene toda la lógica del
mundo porque 5 al cuadrado es 25 y 5 el
cubo 125 y 2.861 está más cercano a 3
que a 2 por lo tanto si nosotros
elevamos el 5 a la potencia de 2.861 o
de hecho sistemas más exactos tendremos
que elevar el 5 a esta potencia que
tenemos aquí arriba pero vamos a
elevarla a nuestro resultado aproximado
a milésimos 2.861 si elevamos el 5 esta
potencia me dan 99 puntos 94 31 que esto
es muy cercano a 100 y de hecho si
quisiéramos que nos diera si entendemos
que elevarlo al resultado con todos los
decimales que nos dio la calculadora
pero bueno aquí ya tenemos nuestro
resultado utilizando el cambio de base
pero todavía no te vayas me gustaría
enseñarte de dónde sale esta fórmula
mágica sale de la nada nunca te has
preguntado por qué
a esta fórmula y bueno para ver esto lo
que quiero que veamos primero es
logaritmo en base a de b
vamos a intentar probar esta fórmula del
cambio de base así que vamos a tomarnos
el lugar y no en base a debemos y vamos
a suponer que esto es igual a otro
número voy a tomarme al número ser
porque porque si yo escribo esto en
nuestro lenguaje exponencial del cual ya
hemos hablado bastante esto lo podemos
escribir la siguiente manera como ha
elevado a la potencia cm
esto es lo mismo que vemos recuerda que
estas dos expresiones son exactamente
iguales déjenme ponerlo con el mismo
color para que vayamos con mucho cuidado
viendo de dónde sale cada una de las
cosas ha elevado a la c es igual a b
esta expresión es equivalente a
tomármelo garino en base a dv igual a c
y bueno qué pasa si ahora yo me tomo el
logaritmo en base en cualquier otra base
o inclusive en base a de ambos lados de
la igualdad como es una igualdad si me
tomo cualquier operación igual de ambos
lados de la ecuación de igualdad se
conserva más aún si yo me tomo por
ejemplo el logaritmo
base no sé vamos a utilizar la base que
queremos la base x el logaritmo en base
x de la primera parte de esta igualdad
de a laxe y después me tomo el logaritmo
en base x de la segunda parte de esta
igualdad es decir el logaritmo en base x
debe pues la igualdad se va a seguir
conservando porque estoy aplicando la
misma operación a ambos lados de mi
igualdad por lo tanto puedo decir que lo
gano en base x de al ac es igual al
hogar y bombas x debe y bueno ahora si
recordamos una de las propiedades de los
logaritmos que hemos visto en estos
últimos vídeos una de ellas me dice que
las potencias siempre bajan
multiplicando el logaritmo es decir que
esto es lo mismo que se veces el
logaritmo envase x de a lo único que
estoy haciendo es bajando la potencia
multiplicando el logaritmo por una de
las propiedades de los logaritmos sé a
veces el logaritmo en base x de amd y
esto es igual al logaritmo en base x
debe muy bien y qué pasa si ahora
despejo hacen vamos a resolver esto para
hacer y bueno para esto lo que voy a
hacer es dividir ambos lados de la
ecuación entre el logaritmo en base x de
amd y entonces me quedaría el logaritmo
en base x de b
entre el logaritmo en base x de am lo
que estoy haciendo es pasando lograr en
un base x de am
del otro lado dividiendo esto por una
parte mientras que por la otra parte c
es igual el logaritmo en base a debe
bueno de hecho espera déjame escribir
todo en los colores originales sé que ya
sabes más o menos por dónde va todo este
asunto pero los colores originales sabe
ver mucho más padre y se va a ver mucho
más entendible así que el logaritmo en
nuestra nueva base x debe entre el
logaritmo en base x en nuestra nueva
base de amd lo que estoy haciendo es
dividiendo ambos lados de la ecuación
entre el logaritmo en base x de amd esto
tiene que ser igual a 100 pero se es
igual al lugar en un base
debe esto porque fue justo de ahí donde
partimos y por lo tanto si se es igual a
esto y es igual a esto entonces estas
dos cosas son iguales logaritmo en base
x debe entre el hogar en base x de amd
es igual de logaritmo base adb lo que es
precisamente mi fórmula del cambio de
base que es lo que yo quería probar que
por cierto en este ejemplo me valía 100
a valía 5
x era nuestra base 10